lancement véritable leçon de solidarité
il avait été annoncée par le président
du conseil européen à l'issue du dernier
sommet ça faisait partie des conclusions
du sommet européen c'est à dire l'idée
est de lancer aujourd'hui un fonds
fiduciaire c'est-à-dire un fonds dans
lequel seront mis toutes les
contributions des pays donateurs qui
sera géré en partie par l'union
européenne et probablement avec l'aide
de la banque mondiale en tout cas
c'était le projet initial le lancement
de ce fonds c'est vraiment porter se
font sur les fonts baptismaux plus
qu'une conférence de plein droit c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle la le
format de cette conférence est plutôt
virtuel on demande aux pays donateurs de
se manifester les européens évidemment
sont déjà sur les starting blocks et il
espère pouvoir faire une élan de
solidarité mondiale ce fonds doit servir
d'abord et avant tout à reconstruire à
long terme l'ukraine ce n'est pas une
aide d'urgence comme celles qu'on voit
actuellement avec par exemple les aides
militaires que l'union européenne a
multiplié depuis le début du conflit ou
bien les aides ponctuelles qui sont ce
qui se chiffrent aussi en milliards
d'euros là pour le coup ce serait des
centaines de milliards d'euros qui
seront nécessaires on a entendu dire
l'ancienne présidente de la banque
centrale ukrainienne que pour la
reconstruction de l'ukraine ça pourrait
se monter à environ 500 milliards
d'euros par an et encore pour l'instant
ce ne sont que des estimations la moitié
de ce montant serait consacré aux
infrastructures et c'est là dessus que
l'union européenne espère commencer ses
travaux le reconstruire les
infrastructures européennes et les
infrastructures ukrainienne pardon avec
en plus des aides spécifiques pour les
entreprises du craignent n ce serait une
sorte de plan marshall qui devrait
permettre qui est censé permettre à
l'ukraine de retomber sur ses pieds et
puis qui pourrait aussi évidemment
bénéficier aux européens qui seront
impliqués en première ligne dans cette
reconstruction de l'ukraine à long terme